here's the big challenge of life you can
have more than you've got because you
can become more than you are
that's the challenge
and of course the other side of the coin
reads unless you change how you are
you'll always have what you got
success is something you attract not
something you pursue
success is looking for a good place to
stay
so instead of going after it you work on
yourself personal development
see the major question to ask on the job
is not what are you getting the major
question to ask on the job is what are
you becoming
the big question is not what am I
getting paid here the big question is
what am I becoming here
because true happiness is not contained
in what you get happiness is contained
in what you become
I have found in my experience that
income does not far exceed personal
development
now sometimes income takes a lucky jump
but sure enough unless you grow out
where it is it'll usually come back
where you are life has strange ways
if somebody hands you a million dollars
best you become a millionaire quickly
so you get to keep the money
otherwise sure enough it'll disappear
but she shelf taught me how to set goals
what a favor that was
one morning at breakfast shortly after I
met him
he said Jim let me see your current list
of goals and let's go over them and talk
about him he said maybe that's the best
way I can help you get a better
Direction started
and I said
I don't have a list he said well is it
out in the car or home somewhere I said
uh no sir
I don't have a list
anywhere
he said well young man that's where we
got to start
he said I can tell you right now if you
don't have a list of your goals with you
he said I can guess your bank balance
within a few hundred dollars
which he did
and that got my attention
I said you mean my bank balance would
change if I had a list of goals he said
drastically
if you're good it'll stand out this idea
that like oh it's easy for you too
everybody's got these stupid barriers
they put in their own head you got to
resist those goddamn things because they
don't do you any good and they certainly
Define the potential for your future in
a negative way that's not self-serving
and it's not even real you know you you
put this artificial ceiling on the
potential for what you're doing if you
hit a wall okay that just means you need
to regroup and rethink it doesn't mean
that Wall's there especially when it
comes to something like social media or
like a podcast something where you're
just you're putting out a piece of art
you're putting out something that you've
created there's no wall as far as like
how many people are going to enjoy it or
how far it's gonna go it's just it is
what it is and if people don't like it
make it better if they like it less fix
that figure out a way to do it you can
do that and this this idea that there's
no way to get past the starting block
today it's just ludicrous it's crazy and
it's just this this poor thinking and
people that are trapped in in bad
situations one of the problems is you
feel like this is your future you feel
like and you can't get out of that
there's no hope there's no light at the
end of the tunnel there's no rainbow and
if you feel like that that alone can be
incredibly defining and limiting but if
you can look at if you look at yourself
objectively and say okay I kind of empty
here I'm in credit card debt I'm working
in a job I I don't like what I'm doing
but I have some ideas I need to feed
those ideas I need to feed them
and water them and I need to set aside a
certain amount of time every day to just
try to make those things happen you can
do that but I had fallen so flat on my
face for the first time in my life I was
depressed asking myself why why me how
can this half I work so hard hard work
pays I always thought
it's not paying for me I got nothing I
literally had seven bucks in my pocket
so my seven dollar story that failure
rising from that I want to say
it's not over forming I'm immediately
going to launch myself into training for
professional wrestling I couldn't have
launched myself with that type of
training that I did every day for hours
in a boxing ring that was stiff like
concrete
every day for hours I couldn't launched
myself with that type of mentality
had I not fallen on my face after 10
years of football failed
sometimes desire waits for a trigger
waits for something to happen who knows
what the happening may be a song the
lyrics a movie the dialogue a seminar a
sermon
a book
an experience confrontation with an
enemy
a conversation with a friend who finally
levels with you whatever the experience
it is it's so valuable and here's my
best advice welcome all experiences
you never know which one is gonna turn
everything
on don't put up the walls
the same wall that keeps out
disappointment keeps out happiness take
down the Walls go for the experience let
it teach you and then the other thing
that people say and this is more like
three quarters of them is that they say
I was in a very dark place I was
addicted I was I was drinking too much I
had a fragmented relationship with my
fiancee and I wasn't getting married uh
things weren't going where very well
with my family my relationship with my
father was damaged I didn't have any aim
I was wasting my time some variant of
that some combination of those and they
said well I've been watching your
lectures I've decided to establish a
purpose I'm trying to tell the truth and
things are way better let's say I've
done maybe eight or nine large-scale
public talks in the last two months so
that's probably 20 000 people and about
half of them a third to half of them
have stayed afterwards to talk to me so
that's about seven thousand people who
have said that to me and then people
stopped me on the street all the time
and tell me exactly that story I have a
purpose man my life actually matters I
finally realized that and I'm putting it
into practice and I'm bearing up under
the heaviest load I can imagine and it's
really healthic it's like God if human
beings are emotional creatures
and emotions are powerful for life
change now of course emotions are so
powerful they can go either way on you
emotions can either build or destroy
so you really have to employ emotions
properly we call civilization the
intelligent management of human emotions
if you can intelligently apply your
emotions in the right direction no
telling what can happen could turn your
life around one day
people have asked me for the last 24
years how do you develop an above
average income and the answer is become
an above average person
develop an above average handshake some
people want to be successful they don't
even work on their handshake as easy as
that would be to start on they let it
slide they don't understand develop an
above average smile develop an above
average excitement develop an above
average interest in other people
develop an above average intensity to
win see that'll change everything
probably one of the most frustrating
experiences in life is looking for an
above average job with above average pay
without becoming an above average person
it's called frustration
how often does winter follow fall
every year regularly for the last six
and a half thousand that we know of see
it is not going to change
now some Winters are long and some are
short and some are hard and some are
easy but they always come right after
Falls it isn't Gonna Change
sometimes you can figure it out
sometimes there's no way to figure it
out sometimes it goes well sometimes it
gets in a knot
sometimes it sails along sometimes it
gets in Reverse see that's not gonna
change
the last 6 000 years reads like this
opportunity mixed with difficulty that's
how it reads it isn't gonna change the
man says well if it isn't going to
change how will my life ever change
answer when
you change
and whether I'm talking to high school
kids or business Executives my message
is always the same and it goes like this
the only way it gets better for you is
when you get better